what's up
fol our coach is a man Hall of Fame
player coach and truly a better person
the hands that don't drop anything a
legend right here oh my goodness did you
me Steve
L come on bro this is like our childhood
like literally this our childhood it's
unbelievable you knew it was coming here
but to actually see it in in True Form
to walk out here it's amazing amazing
this should be a great day imine follow
to Play talky you tried in Minnesota how
was that it's hard to skate I couldn't
do it I can't skate with roller blades
bro I put people on stage though that's
what I did do I put people on St I did
that to you yesterday why are they
throwing the tand like that I know
Seattle that's a sow for you see it the
[Music]
[Applause]
fish
he's hanging on his I thought you start
both of us hanging and waving at first
I'm like are they real up there we start
waving I'm like okay it
[Applause]
is
yeah that was fast too yeah good pass
get to the bucket put the right passer
teamwork baby let's go
C they got it so clean looks like
water oh
hey you thought was com through the
glass I wasn't paying attention and then
the glass you better wake up I thought
he like came through the door or
something what did he see your face
later with that I looked away and then I
came back and like he was right there I
ain't going to lie though that one got
me to I thought he was going through the
[Applause]
glass that's two of them that's two of
them
oh he was scared bro I wonder what being
down two pucks is equivalent
to what the heck why you grab me bro you
I about to fall back no no you no my
tools about to fall back I like that all
you got to do is lean be cool be cool no
we was sitting next to the thing like
right right there it's
crazy but when the puck is coming bro
you're ducking and everything the
natural reaction is the duck bro you
duck like you like no time there's no
way this glass protect they're about to
be making you go in the other room down
in Atlanta with the hockey I got to go
on the desk with gry I met KY I'm like
this is crazy bro he works for TNT bro
he's here he's right I'm about to go
talk to him that's one D I'm like he's
he's the Michael Jordan of hockey bro
like I got to see him I don't even got
to meet him I just got to see just to
see him yeah like I was like man it's
like Jordan yeah yeah he's coming he's
he coming to see gry great
up thank you so
[Music]
much I'm cool crazy you have a coat on
sweater
yeah you have a be on retired his number
23 ladies and gentlemen the one the only
Jamal
Crawford wait till Maran comes out wait
till larger comes out what J buer comes
out it's over it's over he walk he knows
the walk like Stone Cold did
he Stone
[Music]
[Applause]
CET the street
name those two and griffy were rock
stars bro and this they went to
[Applause]
957 yeah this is crazy this is crazy
crazy